et en france on lisait en tout cas
difficile de faire un test sans faire la
queue pendant des heures pas facile non
plus de savoir lequel pratiques et
virologiques ou sérologique
sans compter la course au vaccin dont on
vient de parler engagées par de nombreux
laboratoires on s'y retrouve plus d'où
le thème de notre débat ce soir test
vaccin est ce le grand flou pour en
parler nous sommes en direct avec un
philippe froguel froguel pardon
chercheur professeur à l'impérial
collège de londres et à l'université
lille 2 bonsoir philippe froguel merci
d'être avec nous elles vont côté jérôme
martin médecin généraliste président de
l'union française pour une médecine
libre bonsoir docteur marc cimer
smarties merci également d'être avec
nous alors ce sont des files d'attentes
interminables à en france pour se faire
dépister on l'a vu sur toutes les
chaînes de télé où on l'a même
d'ailleurs parfois vécu un n'est ce pas
nous mêmes des jours après d'attentes
pour attendre le résultat alors que ça
va plus vite il faut bien le dire chez
nos voisins européens comme en allemagne
en grèce comment vous vous expliquer
cette différence on commence par jérôme
marty la différence elle est due au fait
que on voit bien que toute la population
une grande partie de la population de se
faire tester on fait du chalutage dans
la population quelque sorte n'a pas
défini du groupe à risques et tout le
monde y va tout le monde peut y aller en
plus sans ordonnance du médecin
donc ça ça a créé un engouement très
important avec une peur de la population
d'être contaminés donc des gens qui
parfois se font tester plusieurs fois et
des des laboratoires qui sont emboliser
on leur en plus cela fléchi tout le
monde voyait laboratoire plutôt que
choisir de multiplier les sites on
aurait pu demander aux médecins aux
infirmières aux pharmaciens aux
biologistes de de tester ça n'a pas été
le cas
et puis et puis la grande erreur c'est
que on n'a pas voulu définir les lieux à
risque et les groupes à risques et
privilégier les tests dans ces groupes
alors maintenant on en est là voilà des
tests qui sont beaucoup trop lents
beaucoup trop structurellement parce que
il faut il ya il y à cette attente
et puis quand on va voir son médecin on
a déjà commencé avec théorisé toujours
avant les symptômes on va voir son
médecin
deux jours après les symptômes il
allez vous faire tester il faut trois
jours et pour avoir le diagnostic il
faut encore deux jours ce qui veut dire
qu'on obtienne diagnostic dix jours
après d'avoir commencé avec thau risée
du virus ce qui est beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup trop
philippe froguel gérons par marty parle
de de lenteur on évoque de plus en plus
ces tests antigénique dont on vient de
parler vous y croyez vous à 7 à cette
solution s'est pas encore la bonne
stratégie
les tests antigénique sont beaucoup
moins sensibles par définition parce que
l'adn on est on est capable de ce qu'on
appelle de l'amphi l'amplifier c'est à
dire que même si on n'a que quelques
virus on on peut l'augmenter
officiellement ce qui nous permet de le
détecter alors que pour l'anglais non
c'est pas faire et donc s'il ya que très
peu de particules virales dans le nez
bien on les trouvera pas donc c'est
connu c'est rien de nouveau on sait que
la sensibilité est très faible
beaucoup plus faible en tout cas que la
clape et sert mais moi je dois dire une
chose c'est que effectivement on aurait
plus a décidé autrement que d'ouvrir à
tout le monde
les tests pcr mais c'est pas ce qu'a
décidé le gouvernement est donc
maintenant on peut pas revenir en
arrière à mon avis mais la vraie
question c'est pourquoi les laboratoires
privés qui font 90 % des thèses sont
aujourd'hui incapables de faire en 48
heures et s'était engagé à ça et ça
c'est totalement anormal
est ce que des gens comme moi on
proposait depuis très longtemps depuis
le mois de mars avril ses dires des gens
comme moi ces gars de là les gens de la
recherche génomique
nous faisons des dizaines de milliers de
pcr par jour et donc on sait ce que ça
veut dire
on a proposé de s'associer soit des chu
soit des grands groupes de laboratoire
biologique par exemple serbe alliance
par ap
par exemple bio groupe pareil par
exemple synlab et de monter des
plateformes régionales qui
fonctionnerait quand on en a besoin
c'est à dire que si on la ville de
marseille et dans l'état d'épidémie
avancé eh bien il faut à marseille
capable de faire 40 personnes 5 en plus
de personnes voire cent mille personnes
en quelques jours et ça aujourd'hui
personne n'est capable de le faire parce
que le choix de gouvernement
c'est certes un million mais 1 millions
/ 5000 laboratoire or il aurait fallu
faire des grandes plateformes d'e comme
c'est fait par exemple en angleterre
comme ses frères en allemagne il a à ce
moment là on pourra réconcilier savez ce
que mon collègue vient de dire c'est à
dire de le faire dans des endroits au
moment où on a besoin c'est pas
aujourd'hui encore est ce qu'on a besoin
de faire progresser à fait à marseille
c'est en seine saint denis par exemple
ou à paris et vous même à lille et l'as
et bien c'est là où c'est plate forme
serait utile et ça le gouvernement a
refusé de le faire j'ai jamais compris
pourquoi ça ça fait cinq mois qu'on
demande ça n'est pas trop tard mais si
on ne le fait pas vois pas comment on va
s'en sortir les masques on a bien vu que
les masques c'est pas la panacée c'est
un retardateur un masque pas plus c'est
comme quand vous avez un feu de forêt
des canadairs qui leur balance un
retardateur et bien il faut que les
pompiers aient bien les maths ça va
faire que les gens sont moins affectés
au travail dans le métro et tout ça
marche très bien mais c'est pas une
panacée
et donc si on n'a pas les tests rapides
on peut pas isoler les gens on va
écouter martin blachier pilée monazite
avant de redonner la parole à jérôme
marty un médecin de santé publique il
était sur notre antenne et vous allez
l'entendre il est justement très
dubitatif sur l'efficacité des tests que
l'on pratique va sans doute beaucoup de
14 n est quarantaine qui sont inutiles
dans la mesure où on sait que la plupart
des gens qui vont se faire tester sont
des gens qui pensent avoir été en
contact avec le virus qui donc se mettre
en isolement et on sait que confier les
tests on a cinq conscient de positif
donc on va très probablement un grand
nombre de gens qui s'isolent alors que
le contacts qu'ils ont eus avec une
personne commis de plus ce n'est pas
vraiment à risque je pense qu'il
faudrait trier effectivement à la fois
les tests mais aussi les 40 m un film
fort ghana il faisait allusion tout à
l'heure le trir il ya trop de monde
jérôme marty c'est votre analyse
également on n'est pas efficace dans la
façon d'aborder le
le problème nous sommes tous des
scientifiques la base de notre isolement
c'est la logique ça va faire maintenant
des semaines que on teste des centaines
de milliers de personnes
on a en gros entre 3000 et 9000 cas
positifs par jour et qu'on a des équipes
de l'assurance maladie qui font des
enquêtes qu'on appelle le contact racing
où sont les statistiques on a besoin de
ces statistiques on a on a enquêté
auprès de centaines de centaines de
milliers de personnes
moi j'ai besoin de savoir qui se
contaminent quand on se contaminent ou
aux contamines
dans quelles conditions se contaminent
et à partir de là avec des statistiques
fines on sera précisément quels sont les
groupes à risque ou est-ce qu'il faut
taper ou est-ce qu'il faut tester et là
on sera beaucoup plus efficace si on
fait du chantage pour une population
elle si on laisse n'importe qui se
tester on en arrivera par n'importe quel
moyen que l'on fera on aura toujours des
files d'attenté comme le dit martine
blachier
on aura en plus des tests qui
globalement par moment ne servent à rien
à cause des faux positifs etc
il faut véritablement possible l'avons
testé qu'on soit efficace on est dans
une course contre la montre
on voit bien qu'on a les chiffres qui
montrent on va très probablement vers
une augmentation des hospitalisations et
des animations qui va continuer si on
veut casser cette épidémie on a besoin à
la fois des moyens de prévention et on a
besoin de tester efficacement donc c'est
non seulement les tests efficaces mais
quand je dis tester efficacement
c'est vraiment aller vers les groupes à
risque comme le fait de rester dans
l'album philippe froguel à un autre
problème que rencontre effectivement les
potentiels contaminées depuis des
semaines on a vu ces tests contre le
coronavirus se multiplier comme des
petits pains il ya les tests
sérologiques dont on parle souvent les
tests virologiques les écouvillon les
tests sanguins on est
un petit peu perdues en tant que patient
sur celui qu'on doit faire réellement
comment s'en sortir justement est ce qui
est assez de pédagogie selon vous pour
l'instant on n'a pas beaucoup de choix
puisque les seuls qui sont autorisés
homologue lists et les tests pcr a pas
terminé
ou alors les tests sérologiques qui ne
servent à rien pour diagnostiquer
quelqu'un qui n'a juste être d'être
contaminés donc pour l'instant on en est
là alors le gouvernement dit qu'il y
aura des tests antigénique bientôt bon
alors on pourra les utiliser
ça sera ça sera déjà quelque chose
malgré leurs limites
et puis il ya les fameux tests
salivaires nous on avait proposé au
gouvernement quand je dis nous c'est à
dire les chercheurs un décennie somme
avait proposé au gouvernement au mois
d'avril a travaillé sur les tests
salivaires
on nous a en gros répondu qu' on
n'intéresse personne et que ce n'était
pas utile que les tests sérologiques
avait remplacé tout parce que ça c'est
une chose que je peux vous garantir
c'est que au moins de mars avril à
comité de conseil scientifique monsieur
delfraissy les autres pensaient que
ignorait que les tests sérologiques des
films dont fait une erreur
méthodologique et l'homme et c'est aussi
pour ça qu'on n'a pas développé les
alternatives antigénique pcr salivaires
et autres parce que il ya eu cette
illusion eux les tests sérologiques
allait remplacer à tous parce qu'on
vivait en temps sur l'histoire de
l'archivé et autres donc y'a rien
d'extraordinaire aujourd'hui les tests
salivaires
c'est très bien mais bon ça demande un
prélèvement salivaire il y aura là que
pour pour cracher au lieu d'avoir la
coupe pour le nez mais ça va pas changer
fondamentalement les chevaux sauf que ça
fait moins mal et que peut-être ils font
du personnel qui soit un peu moins bien
formés mais vidée pas forêt mais aussi
des problèmes d'homologation easy cover
on a eu avant l'été une société
montpelliéraine qui qui travaille avec
des chercheurs comme vous
du cnrs à montpellier qui travaillent
sur ces tests mais on a du mal à les
homologué pourquoi c'est aussi long
jérôme marty pour répondre à cette
question je sais pas c'était cette
structure est la nôtre notre régime
administratif c'est tout à fait possible
c'est qu'on a une lourdeur
administrative profonde de beaucoup de
proto paul beaucoup de procédures que à
chaque fois comme le disait coluche ont
fermé gardien il fallait des nuages de
fumée etc
c'est très franco-français ce système là
quoi ces voix là c'est la seule
explication que je peux avoir la
lourdeur administrative mais pour
revenir sur les tests salivaires le
grand avantage aussi qu'il y aurait
avait des tests rapides et non
traumatique c'est le test groupe et le
test à l'entreprise etc où on peut faire
ce qu'on appelle le pooling c'est à dire
on peut tester mettons 60 personnes on
va mettre tout ça dans le même réactif
si leur actif et positif on va prétexter
individuellement
s'il est négatif on écarte cette
personne et on veut donc pour on voit
donc qu'on peut faire du test répétitif
groupés et là je pense en particulier
aux sportifs aux sportifs de haut niveau
mais c'est aussi deux de moins haut
niveau on pourrait très bien comme ça
regardez si une équipe est est positive
ou non et si elle est poussière n'est
pas positive et autres moyens évidemment
de lutins on en parle tous les jours
contre cette épidémie c'est le vaccin la
panacée en tout le monde l'attend tous
les grands labos sont sur le coup
philippe froguel comment savoir ce qui
va marcher le lieu on a vu que la russie
commence à tester trump qui nous promet
un vaccin avant les élections tout le
monde s'y met
est ce que vous êtes optimiste sur ce
point là oui je suis je suis optimiste
enfin un petit peu moins depuis que il
ya eu un effet secondaire grave chez
astrazeneca
mais en tout cas pour le vaccin russe et
tout le monde a moqué eh bien il ya un
article dans le journal de langue 7 que
le grand journal mondial est pour
l'instant cet art et sur les essais de
phase 1 et 2 il n'y a pas de vrai gros
problème donc il ya quelques candidats
qui sont en phase iii c'est à dire la
phase où on fait dix mille vingt mille
cinquante et une personnes
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure de 48 le
russe c'est à peu près la même chose en
angleterre ou aux états unis
eh bien j'espère j'espère que s'il n'y a
pas d'effets secondaires dramatique
eh bien on pourra utiliser ces vaccins à
la fin d'année au début de l'année
prochaine c'est vrai que ça changerait
tout jérôme marty faut que tous les
français se mettaient à lire le long de
7 pour savoir en afrique ce qui est bon
ce qui est pas bon comme le vaccin parce
qu'il ya peut-être beaucoup de
désinformation aussi là dessus on l'a vu
très clairement je crois que si on avait
une soul est une bonne nouvelle pour le
pôle boxer elle sera diffusée sur le
plan mondial assez rapidement nommé là
dans le problème on parle de poids on
parle d'une pandémie c'est quelque chose
d'assez extraordinaire ça veut dire que
sur la terre entière les hommes
connaissent à un stade plus ou moins
avancé la même problématique ce qui
n'arrive normalement jamais ça veut dire
que si on trouve le vaccin même
structurellement ça va prendre du temps
parce qu'il faut avoir les usines il
faut avoir les zones il faut avoir les
contenants il faut qu'on produise pour
des milliards d'êtres humains
donc il sait pas c'est pas le tout de le
trouver je crois que le trouve et on le
tour on y arrivera mais structurellement
cependant aussi de temps du temps pour
le produire et puis vous avez le poème
de l'égalité je rappelle que la vie de
nos européens vont pas plus que celle de
l'afrique un an que celle de l'indien
donc il va falloir que l'ensemble de la
terre sont servis en même temps ça
poserait problème
une dernière petite question parce que
le temps file le gouvernement va devoir
prendre des décisions difficiles c'est
ce qu'a déclaré cet après midi le
président du conseil scientifique
gabriella talent qui a d'ailleurs dit
qu' aucune solution n'était à exclure
ça veut dire quoi philippe froguel con
on va nous confiner ça nous pend au nez
ça ça veut dire qu'on est fataliste et
que le gouvernement n'a pas tiré les
leçons de tous les échecs qu'on a depuis
quelques mois alors que on est on est de
très nombreux à dire qu'il faut changer
les choses
faire les tests différemment enfin on
dit on dit à peu près tous les mêmes
choses et je suis vraiment très étonné
même conseil scientifique et le
gouvernement dise bas ça n'a pas marché
et puis on va être obligé de recombiner
puisque c'est en gros ce que j'ai cru
comprendre à je trouve pas ça très
optimiste nous non plus merci philippe
froguel merci jérôme marty d'avoir
accepté ce décryptage ce débat avec nous
en direct sur rt france merci à vous